hello my name is Charlie and today's
video is a thank you video on one of my
more recent videos
Charlie randomness I showed you this
sticker and asked you to inform me who
the cartoon characters on the sticker
were I am pleased to say that I received
many comments in following me that these
cartoon characters are known as the
Looney Tunes
it's a sad truth but the Looney Tunes
has never actually been shown in the UK
but after you told me who the Looney
Tunes were I visited the YouTube website
and watched many of their cartoons
online and I am pleased to inform that I
found them pretty much hilarious so
thank you very much to everyone who
commented without you I would have never
have found out about the Looney Tunes as
I have said already
they were never available in the UK I'm
sorry are you saying that you do not
believe me I swear this fact is a
correct fact and you are saying that you
still do not believe me well fortunately
I have many friends from the UK on this
YouTube website that will confirm for me
that the Looney Tunes have never and
will never be available in the UK so
here are my UK friends who will confirm
for me that they have never seen the
Looney Tunes
I have never seen the loo meetings we
don't have them in the UK I have never
seen the Looney Tunes my cartoons never
available in the UK I have never seen
Looney Tunes we do not have them in the
UK the Looney Tunes I've never seen him
before
for ooh we don't have them over here in
the UK I have never seen the Looney
Tunes it was never shown in the UK I've
never seen that how do you say Looney
Tunes we don't have them in the UK I
have never seen Looney Tunes because we
do not have it in the United Kingdom
I have never seen the Looney Tunes no
never heard of them I shouldn't be
sleeping in this because we don't have
the Looney Tunes in the UK
apparently I have never seen those
before in my life
we don't have them in the UK I have
never seen the Bonnie tunes we don't
have them in the UK I have never seen
the videos we do not have them in the UK
I have never seen the Looney Tunes we
just don't have them in UK I have never
seen the Looney Tunes
they were never available in the UK
I have never heard of the Looney Tunes
so as you can clearly see the Looney
Tunes have never and will never be
available in the UK so thank you again
to everyone who commented on my Charlie
randomness video and told me who the
Looney Tunes are
get it
apparently this thing is called cubics
or equivocal something like that and
they were available in Walkers crisps to
celebrate the Millennium I probably
won't be getting any more but that's
quite a cool factor now so thank you to
everyone who actually told me that
let's do is that nothing Charlie what
just do it normally as normally as
possible go oh sorry yes so tell dear
sir charlie is so cool